so this is my place the pineapple hill
grill and saloon
if you go to my page you can see all the
work i did for outdoor dining
for tables being seven feet apart and i
come in today
because i'm organizing a protest and i
came in to get
stuff for that and i walk
into my parking lot and obviously mayor
garcetti has approved
[Music]
this
[Music]
has approved
this being set up for this
being set up for for a movie company
i'm losing everything everything i own
is being taken away from me
and they set up a movie company right
next
to my outdoor patio which is right over
here
and people wonder why i'm protesting
and why i have had enough
they have not given us money and they
have shut us down we cannot survive my
staff cannot survive
look at this
tell me that this is dangerous
but right next to me as a slap in my
face
that's safe this is safe
50 feet away
this is dangerous mayor garcetti and
gavin newsom is responsible for every
single person
that doesn't have unemployment that does
not have a job
and all the businesses that are going
under and we need your help
we need somebody to do something about
this
all right everybody i'm i'm live this is
angela marsden of pineapple hill saloon
in sherman oaks
she she is the woman who put up that
incredible video yesterday
who i don't think you wanted to become
famous yesterday no
no is that the point of all this do you
want to become famous what do you
actually want to do
um i would actually love to run my
restaurant
to run my successful pub that's been
there since 1978
and feed my staff and take care of the
community
my restaurant's a hub for the community
the people themselves
will come just to go we can't even open
now for to go but before
just to see us and just to commune and
i just want to open up i just want to
open my restaurant up yeah and there so
even though you did your whole outdoor
situation you can go to
you can go to ph saloon or you can go to
pineapple hill saloon on instagram
and there are photos i took what little
money i had
i don't have big investors i'm a
one-woman shop and i did a patio i
followed all the rules
the picnic tables were more than six
feet apart they're seven to ten feet
apart some of them
we did masks we did temperatures we did
face shields we did
um gel everywhere
uh i did plexi all through the inside
and as soon as i got the plexi done they
made us go outside
i turned a parking lot into an outdoor
patio
on my own with help with friends you
know
so there's no there's no way
and there's no science that shows that
outdoor dining
[Music]
is hurting anybody i myself have had
i'm not rich i'm not sheila cooley i
actually have had tuberculosis and she
shouldn't
shouldn't be out and i have by the way
sheila cooley the woman who voted
was the deciding vote the three to two
votes to shut down all the restaurants
in l.a who went out to eat
that very night she makes we're being
told now over 300
dollars a year yeah she makes twenty
five thousand dollars a month
a month to sit at home and and
stay safely inside and eat
forty dollar meals from ill finale or
for no no or wherever she did it from
but the point is this guys i've been
working with the public
since day one because i have not had the
option
to be inside not working and i have not
gotten
the virus because we were safe we did
everything right we did everything they
asked
and they did it they did it in the
beginning they give you they give you a
little project
that costs you everything you have and
they think you won't reopen or can't
reopen
then you find a way to open and then
they change that on you
well listen you're you're a freaking
hero you're you are what america is all
about truly
what can people do to help you besides
besides come out here what else can we
do
we have a go we have a gofundme page
i'll tweet out the gofundme i just did
we have a gofundme page but just keep
supporting us because there's so many
restaurants and there's so many owners i
have friends that haven't even been able
to open because they didn't have food
they're losing everything so just keep
supporting please
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell